not all good things can last forever but
some of these 2000s cartoons got pulled
away before their time was too much
money to blame if you thought aqua teen
hunger force was weird just wait until
you find out why its creators say it was
cancelled
one of the biggest cartoons of the 2000s
nickelodeon's avatar the last airbender
spawned several comics as well as a
sequel series the legend of korra in
2010 a live-action adaptation of avatar
the last airbender hit theaters and
bombed spectacularly according to the
critic's consensus on rotten tomatoes
the m night shyamalan film ended up with
a devastating critic score of just 5
percent the worst thing about it is that
nickelodeon reportedly only acts the
cartoon because shyamalan showed an
interest in making a future film former
head writer for the series aaron ehas
tweeted in 2019 truthfully there was a
moment in time when we all thought we
would do a fourth season of avatar the
last airbender then along came m night
shyamalan defended his movie during an
interview with ign reminding everyone
that he had made it for kids saying you
could make it for that same audience
which is what i did for 9 and 10 year
olds or you could do the transformers
version and have megan fox or you could
have gone with the third option and made
it you know a good movie at least that
night can go back to the show for some
comfort
i'm not looking for anyone's approval
i know who i am teen titans go has grown
into the jewel in the cartoon network
crown since it started airing in 2013
but there's a certain section of the dc
fandom that can't stand the show namely
fans of the original teen titans the
first animated iteration of the teenage
superhero team debuted in 2003 and their
adventures were initially scheduled to
last for a total of four seasons the
show's popularity led to a fifth season
and the way that ended made it seem as
though a6 was definitely in the pipeline
but it never materialized viewers began
to panic when a source close to the show
told the blog titans tower that the
chances of getting a sixth season were
slim the blog attempted to mobilize fans
but their protests were in vain cartoon
network acts the superhero series in
2006. there's been plenty of rumors
about who is to blame for the
cancellation in the year since with some
blaming cartoon network and others
pointing the finger at warner brothers
animation who created the show david
slack a former producer on teen titans
said in a 2017 tweet that he's quote
heard different answers from different
people some have told him that the
ratings foul because the trigon season
was too scary for its target audience
but others said that it was mattel that
wanted it killed the company entered
into a master toy license agreement with
cartoon network in 2006 and bandai had
the show's toy deal
invader zim is regularly ranked among
nickelodeon's best shows despite the
fact that it didn't even make it to the
end of its second season created by
writer and cartoonist and vasquez the
show was pulled after just 27 episodes a
christmas special aired in december 2002
then zim disappeared but why according
to vasquez it was a mixture of things he
wrote in a 2010 blog post in the end
even i couldn't give you the whole
inaccurate truth for why the show got
pulled the most likely culprits are
simply ratings and the sheer expense of
the show which was monstrously expensive
at the time according to richard horvitz
who voiced the title character the
september 11th attacks likely played a
big part in invader zim's demise as he
told sci-fi at that time given the mood
of the country at the time i don't think
people wanted to see shows that were
about any kind of destruction or
anything that had to do with someone
trying to conquer the earth long before
phil lord and chris miller spearheaded
hollywood franchises they created a
cartoon that launched their careers and
got a lot of attention overseas clone
high which followed teenage clones of
historical figures as they navigated
high school together debuted in 2002 but
it was pulled the following year after
just a single 13 episode season mtv
didn't cancel the show due to low
ratings or poor critical reception
instead the network was forced to act
after a massive outcry over the
portrayal of mahatma gandhi or gandhi's
clone as it were lord and miller
portrayed gandhi as a particularly horny
teenager and it didn't go over well in
india joan and cleo living together if
that curtain wasn't there i'd be seeing
some naughty babe on chick action right
about now
the show never aired there but when
people caught wind of what clone high
had done to one of their national
treasures there were hunger strikes and
calls to have mtv's license to broadcast
in india revoked miller told
entertainment weekly i guess not all
publicity is good publicity as it turns
out it was a really crazy story but they
didn't want us to talk about it at all
we were sort of gagged about it for
years however in 2021 lord and miller
revealed that hbo max has ordered two
seasons for a revival the 1990s animated
spider-man series is often considered
the best of all the web slingers
cartoons but for gen z kids it's all
about the spectacular spider-man the
show which debuted in march 2008 and
lasted until november 2009 was well
received by fans and critics alike so
why did sony stop making it in short the
studio gave up its spider-man tv rights
which returned fully to marvel instead
of continuing with the popular the
spectacular spider-man marvel decided to
wipe the slate clean and start over with
a brand new spidey show ultimate
spider-man according to the spectacular
spider-man's supervising producer and
story editor greg wiseman nobody at
marvel contacted him about continuing
the show after the right switch which he
took as a sign he told ign i've heard
nothing directly from marvel but i think
the ultimate spider-man announcement
makes it fairly clear that spectacular
is over
the simpsons was never going to be an
easy act to follow but matt groening
thinks he did a pretty good job with
futurama the animated sci-fi sitcom
debuted in 1999 and got off to a rocky
start raining wanted futurama to air
directly after the simpsons on a sunday
evening but fox only kept it there for
two episodes before shifting the show to
a tuesday the way granny tells it the
network had it in for his new show right
from the start he told chortle in 2003
the people at fox didn't ever support
the show and it wasn't to their taste
and in my opinion they're out of their
minds but they don't like the simpsons
either the idea of a tv show that they
haven't gotten their greasy fingers all
over creatively drives them nuts that's
why almost everything else is so lousy
yes i'm afraid the brainless drones who
run the network canceled our license
[Applause]
fortunately granny got the chance to
continue the story when futurama was
picked up by comedy central in 2008 it
ran until 2013 when it was canceled
again but then in 2022 plans were
announced for another series revival
this time courtesy of hulu
it's never been the most well-known
disney channel cartoon but american
dragon jake long was reportedly pretty
popular with viewers during its two-year
run jake long even showed up in an
episode of lilo and stitch the series
seemingly indicating that the mouse
house saw the character as a keeper that
wasn't the case however american dragon
jake long was cancelled after two
seasons in 2007. it seems the damage was
done when the powers that be decided to
change the animation style in an
interview shared by a fan site set up to
save the show creator jeff good said the
second season had a different director
and we decided to take the opportunity
to try some things with the art that we
didn't get a chance to do in the first
season whatever the ultimate reason for
the cancellation efforts to get a third
season greenlit were ultimately
unsuccessful
at the turn of the millennium filmmaker
kevin smith held some real sway the new
jersey native burst onto the scene with
the slacker comedy clerks in 1994 and
quickly established himself as the new
voice of gen x with 1995's mall rats and
1997's chasing amy smith hyped up clerks
the animated series ahead of its
premiere in may 2000 but to call it a
short-lived series would be an
understatement abc yanked it just two
episodes into the six episode order so
what happened well according to the
pittsburgh post gazette when abc picked
up clerks it was in third place as a
network and it was willing to take
chances on smith's bizarre project
however the head honchos at disney
weren't crazy about the series which in
turn affected abc's opinion on the show
secondly who wants to be a millionaire
came along and brought a massive
audience over to the channel and as
smith himself put it before nothing was
working now they don't need risky and
risque projects like ours
a wonderfully weird show that aired for
three seasons during the twilight of the
2000s ch greenblatt's chowder won a
prime time emmy and was nominated for
six annie awards during its run the
cartoon network series debuted in 2007
but greenblatt had been working on it
for several years by that stage he told
toonzone i think it was probably a
concept that i was doodling back when i
was working on spongebob i was just kind
of filling sketchbooks full of ideas so
probably the late 90s beginning of 2000
chowder's cancellation wasn't related to
its performance it was simply the victim
of a change in strategy in an effort to
compete with nickelodeon and disney's
live-action content cartoon network
introduced a new block called cnreal
debuting a bunch of kid-friendly reality
shows execs had a risky new vision for
the channel and chowder wasn't a part of
it so greenblatt used the free time to
plan a vacation to japan saying on his
nerd ahmada blog i didn't really think
there'd be this many upsides to having a
show officially cancelled by a network
but i'm feeling happier than i've been
in a long time
nothing encapsulates the irreverence of
2000s late night cartoons quite like
aqua teen hunger force
where do you two think you're going
where the hell we want not without me
we're going to see little brittle at the
old folks home go without me the
longtime king of cartoon network's adult
swim block dave willis and matt molero
show about three living food items
sharing a rundown place in new jersey
began as a spin-off of space ghost coast
to coast however it would soon surpass
the parity talk show in terms of
popularity aqua teen hunger force
debuted in 2000 and would go on to
dominate for a decade and then some
running until 2015. when malero and
willis sat down with vice days after the
first episode of the final season
premiered the co-creators took aim at
the network saying it's actually quite
shocking and a bummer at the same time
the show does well it generates a lot of
revenue it's not too expensive to make
so for them to let it go is just a bit
odd we call it odd behavior the pair
doubled down on these claims during an
interview with wabe a few weeks later
both men were adamant that the show was
still generating plenty of cash saying
they've got tired of the trucks pulling
up and dumping it on the loading dock it
wasn't our decision
after creating dexter's laboratory for
cartoon network guindy tartokovsky
became one of the company's biggest
assets it wasn't long before tartakovsky
came to them with another original idea
one less about the laughs and more about
action as he told indie wire i pitched
it as it's a samurai who gets
transplanted into the future he walks
around and fights robots with his sword
and there's not a lot of dialogue and
it's super stylized and then we went for
it samurai jack debuted in 2001 and
quickly gained a cult following but it
came to an abrupt end in 2004 with no
conclusion offered did cartoon network
lose interest in jack's journey or was
tartakovsky the one that decided to call
it quits the truth is it was mutual with
the creator telling the verge at the end
of the fourth season we were all burnt
out the network didn't know what they
wanted to do i didn't know what i wanted
to do so tartakovsky decided to finish
the series at four seasons when he was
offered the chance to spearhead star
wars clone wars but luckily for him and
samurai jack fans he got the chance to
wrap the story up with a mini-series in
2017
check out one of our newest videos right
here those even more looper videos about
your favorite cancelled shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you